>> Laura: TIME FOR A "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE" INVESTIGATION.
WHO ARE THE PEOPLE BEHIND THE
CARAVANS MANY THINKER WREAKING
HAVOC?
CERTAIN GROUPS INSIDE THE
COUNTRY ARE THE CHIEF DRIVERS.
AT THE TIP OF THE SPHERE IS AN
ADVOCACY GROUP AND WE HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED THEM MANY TIMES ON
THE SHOW, PRETTY MUCH BEFORE
ANYONE WAS TALKING ABOUT THEM.
THEY ARE DESCRIBED ON THEIR
HOME PAGE AS A COLLECTIVE OF
FRIENDS IN PERMANENT SOLIDARITY
WITH DISPLACED PEOPLE.
SOUNDS PRETTY NICE.
THE FOLKS IN CHARGE OF THE GROU
GROUP, ROBERTO CORONA, MEXICAN
BORN AMERICAN.
AND A DUAL CITIZEN ARRESTED IN
MEXICO EARLIER AFTER HE
OBSTRUCTED MEXICAN POLICE
EFFORTS.
THERE IS THE AMERICAN PROJECT
COORDINATOR WITH PLAY BLOW IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S A SISTER GROUP TO THE
CHICAGO-BASED ENTITY.
FRONTERAS IS THE WORD FOR BORDE
BORDER.
THE PASTOR AT A CHURCH IN
CHICAGO.
WE TOLD YOU HOW THE CHURCH
GROUPS CAN BE USED TO BLUR THE
LINE.
CATHOLIC CHURCH, A LOT OF PEOPLE
KNOW I'M A CATHOLIC.
THEY GET ALMOST $100 MILLION A
YEAR TO RESETTLE REFUGEES AND
MIGRANTS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
WHEN I LAID OUT AS A SMALL PART
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO EXPOSE
THOSE GROUPS AND INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED IN THIS.
THEY HELPED ORGANIZE THE CARAVAN
STARTING IN HONDURAS AND
GUATEMALA AND ALSO AMERICAN
IMMIGRATION LAWYERS AT THE SAME
TIME ARE ALSO INVOLVED.
JOINING US NOW, WE ARE DELIGHTED
THEY ARE WITH US, AN
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER WHO
RECENTLY TOOK A DEEP DIVE INTO
THE ACTIVISTS BEHIND THE EFFORT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
ALLEN, LET'S START WITH YOU.
THE ARGUMENT FROM SOME AND I AM
ONE OF THEM IS THAT THIS SEEMS
TO GO BEYOND CHARITABLE EFFORTS
TO ACTUALLY ORGANIZING PEOPLE IN
FOREIGN COUNTRIES AND LARGE
GROUPS TO EVENTUALLY OVERWHELM
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
IS THAT ACCURATE?
>> FOR AMERICAN IMMIGRATION
LAWYERS, WE ARE NOT IN FOREIGN
COUNTRIES.
WE ARE ADDRESSING INDIVIDUALS,
EITHER WOMEN, CHILDREN, MEN WHO
HAVE BEEN DETAINED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE ARE NOT DOING THE OUTREACH
ABROAD.
>> Laura: THERE ARE SOME
AMERICAN LAWYERS.
>> THEY ARE NOT PART OF OUR
ORGANIZATION.
THOSE PEOPLE WHO CALL THEMSELVES
GOOD SAMARITANS WHO ARE DOING
THAT, WHAT THEY FEEL TO BE GOD'S
WORK, THEY DON'T NECESSARILY --
>> Laura: A LOT OF THEM ARE
DOING THE COACHING.
LAWYERS FROM SAN FRANCISCO, THEY
WON'T COME ON, AND THEY ARE
LITERALLY DOWN IN THESE CAMPS
SAYING THIS IS HOW THE PROCESS
GOES.
YOU HAVE TO SHOW CREDIBLE FEAR.
THIS IS WHAT CREDIBLE FEAR LOOKS
LIKE.
IT'S BASICALLY COACHING PEOPLE.
>> SOME OF IT IS COACHING AND
SOME OF IT IS BEING A LAWYER.
>> Laura: YOU CAN'T ADVISE
THEM TO LIVE.
>> WE CAN TELL THEM WHAT THE
CRITERIA IS FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO GET INTO THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: MOST OF THEM ARE
ECONOMIC MIGRANTS.
THEIR CLAIMS ARE REJECTED.
THESE ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
ECONOMIC MIGRANTS WHO WANT TO BE
HERE, WITH FAMILY MEMBERS AND
FRIENDS AND WANT TO WORK HERE.
>> IF THEY REALLY ARE ECONOMIC
MIGRANTS, THEY PROCESS THEM,
DENY THE CASES AND SEND THEM
OUT.
IT'S A BORDER ISSUE.
THE MIGRANTS AS I'M HERE TO
WORK, THEN WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SAY NO THAT'S NOT ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR THE GROUNDS TO STAY
HERE.
AS LAWYERS, WE ARE SAYING
PROCESS THE INDIVIDUALS.
DON'T SEND THE MILITARY.
SEND JUDGES AND SOCIAL WORKERS.
>> Laura: FROM THE MEXICAN
STANDPOINT, POLLING CAME OUT
TODAY, 55% SUPPORT TOUGHER
MEASURES IN FUTURE CARAVANS.
52% SUPPORT BLOCKING THEM FROM
ENTERING THE COUNTRY WITHOUT
LEGAL DOCUMENTATION, A VERY BIG
MEXICAN NEWSPAPER.
I READ PART OF IT IN SPANISH.
I AM TRYING TO GET MY SPANISH
BACK.
NOT QUITE THERE YET.
WHAT ABOUT HOW THIS IS PLAYING
IN MEXICO?
SEEMS LIKE EVERY REPORTER DOWN
THERE AS TELLING TALES OF WOE IN
TIJUANA.
>> MEXICO IS PAYING THE PRICE,
RIGHT?
ULTIMATELY, AS TUCKER CARLSON
HAS POINTED OUT, IT'S PILES OF
GARBAGE BEING LEFT OVER BY THIS
MASSIVE CARAVAN OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE MOVING UP FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA.
THEY HAVEN'T CROSSED OVER INTO
THE UNITED STATES YET.
IT'S MEXICO THEY ARE SITTING IN,
THE MEXICAN PEOPLE ARE PAYING
THE PRICE FOR THAT.
THEY WANT THESE PEOPLE TO FOLLOW
MEXICAN LAW.
THEY HAVE ALREADY SHOWN A
DISDAIN FOR MEXICAN NATIONAL
SOVEREIGNTY BY VIOLATING THEIR
BORDERS AND GOING INTO MEXICO.
>> Laura: YESTERDAY POINTED
OUT BASICALLY A VERY SERIOUS
CRIMINAL PROVISION THAT CAN BE
VIOLATED BY ANYONE KNOWINGLY
AIDING AND ABETTING THOSE TO
COME HERE TO GAME THE SYSTEM,
VIOLATE OUR IMMIGRATION LAWS.
SERIOUS REPERCUSSIONS IF SOMEONE
DIES AS A RESULT OF ILLEGAL
EFFORTS.
THERE ARE LAWS ON THE BOOKS THAT
EXIST THAT CAN BE USED TO
PROSECUTE INDIVIDUALS WHO HELP
CONSPIRED TO VIOLATE IMMIGRATION
LAW.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU HAVE
FOUND IN YOUR INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTING THAT WOULD INDICATE
THAT THERE IS RAMPANT LEGAL
PROBLEMS WITH WHAT'S BEING DONE
ON THE SO-CALLED HUMANITARIAN
SIDE?
>> I THINK IN THE UNITED STATES,
YOU HAVE ORGANIZATIONS AND YOU
POINTED OUT TWO OF THEM.
THERE IS A THIRD ONE, THE UNITED
LATIN FAMILIES.
THAT ORGANIZATION, ALL THREE OF
THEM ARE PUSHING WHAT A
NONPROFIT CAN GET AWAY WITH.
THE PERSON WHO RUNS THEM HAS
ENDORSED CANDIDATES FOR PUBLIC
OFFICE, THE ILLINOIS --
USING METHODIST CHURCH
LETTERHEAD.
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE SHOWN A
MASSIVE DISDAIN FOR WHAT
NONPROFITS SHOULD BE ENGAGING
IN, BOTH RELIGIOUS AND SECULAR
NONPROFITS.
>> Laura: A LOT OF THESE
CHURCHES, THEY WANT BODIES IN
THE PEWS.
HER CHURCH, I BELIEVE THE
REGISTERED 1600 SEOUL -- 600,
EXCUSE ME.
IS IT A CHURCH, ACTIVIST GROUP,
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING?
IT'S A LOT OF THINGS AT ONCE.
WHAT ARE THE MOTIVATIONS AND ARE
THERE LEGAL RAMIFICATIONS WHEN
SOME OF THIS SO-CALLED ACTIVISM
IS ORGANIZING PEOPLE FROM
WIDE-RANGING VIOLATIONS OF U.S.
IMMIGRATION.
>> I WILL NOT SAY THERE ARE NOT
PEOPLE WHO VIOLATE THE LAW.
BUT IT'S NOT RAMPANT OVERALL.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU IS MEXICO,
WHILE THEY ARE SAYING THESE
THINGS ABOUT IMMIGRANTS, ARE